you cannot have a functioning Society
without a rich atmosphere of gratitude
gratitude felt and demonstrated by the
younger Generations towards those who
came before and gave them everything
that they have and this gratitude should
be especially extended to uh to and
begin with your family and your direct
benefactor but it should go beyond that
to your nation and your nation's
forebears now this doesn't mean that you
have to pretend that your family was
perfect or your country is perfect
gratitude doesn't require Perfection it
shouldn't require it what it means is
that you recognize what was built for
you what was provided to you what
sacrifices were made for you and for
your sake and that this recognition
breeds respect and loyalty and humility
and a palpable sense of thankfulness